-Our first guest tonight is
a legendary comedian and actor
who you know from films such as
"Uncut Gems," "The Wedding
Singer," and "Happy Gilmore,"
and, of course, his time on
"Saturday Night Live."
He executive produced
and stars in "Hustle,"
which is in select theaters now
and on Netflix tomorrow.
Please welcome back to the show
our very good friend,
Adam Sandler, everybody!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
Welcome back!
-Thank you. Hi, everybody.
Thank you.
-I'm so happy to have you here.
-I'm so -- that was --
That Post Malone thing
was so fun.
-We got after it.
We got after it a little bit.
-How did nobody throw up?
-Um...
I'm not saying nobody did.
[ Laughter ]
The magic of editing
is very helpful.
-Oh, my God
-Adam, a little worried.
You got a --
Something happened here.
You got a black eye.
-I wish it was...
I've been telling people that
I fought Jake Paul.
[ Laughter ]
I was just in bed and my phone
flew up and --
So I just -- I've been
talking about it today.
I feel like an idiot
saying it again,
but I was stuffed in a bed.
You know when they tuck you in
the bed and they don't un--
they tuck it under the thing?
-Yeah.
-Like that?
You make the decision before
you get in bed, you go,
"Do I want to struggle
pulling that?
Let me just get in there."
I didn't pull,
so I got in there,
and then, like, 4:00
in the morning I was like,
"Why did I...?"
My stupid phone was --
I was kicking the thing,
and it flew in the air
and hit me in the face.
[ Laughter ]
-Don't let anybody tell you
that's an embarrassing story.
That's a great way
to get a black eye.
Fortunately, I guess that
happened after this.
At least you did not have a --
-Yes.
-You gave the commencement
at your alma mater.
-Yes, NYU. Yes, yes, yes.
Great day.
[ Applause ]
-This is stressful, though,
right?
-Oh, my God!
Once I said that I'm doing that,
I was so terrified
to do the speech,
because it meant a lot to me.
I wanted everybody
to be happy.
I knew everyone's
families were there.
It's...anyways.
I worked hard
and we had a great time.
Do you know --
I'll tell you this.
This is funny.
Fred, I think you'll like this.
When I was, like, getting...
I did "Punch Drunk Love,"
and I was so excited
I did a cool movie,
blah blah blah blah.
I was like, I bet my NYU, those
guys will like that movie there.
'Cause I was always doing
comedies and stuff.
It's pretty serious
at that school.
So I was like, "They'll like
'Punch Drunk Love.'"
So me and Paul Thomas Anderson
got invited to talk to
the film school,
and I remember walking
out there going,
"This is pretty cool, man.
I made something of myself."
I sit down and I'm with PTA,
next to him,
and literally every question --
"Any questions for these guys?"
Every question, "Mr. Anderson,
uh, what camera did
you use in 'Boogie Nights'?"
Literally, like, 30 in a row.
I was going...
[ Laughter ]
They're just asking
Mr. Anderson everything,
because he's the king of film.
And I was just like,
"You know, when I did
Bobby Boucher..."
[ Laughter ]
Anyways.
-You got that,
where you get sweaty and
you start looking for it.
-I'm like, do I look at Paul,
too, and ask him something?
How did you do --
-It's fantastic.
We've talked in the past
about your girls,
16 and 13?
-Yes.
-They're growing up.
-Yeah. It hurts.
It hurts.
So that my daughters
and that boys are now
going be involved
with their life and that.
-How are you feeling
about that?
-Very nervous very and tense.
I'm not very comfortable
with that.
I think I'm more comfortable
with my wife
bringing home somebody.
[ Laughter ]
I would actually feel
like, alright.
I have more in common with,
like --
boy that is age, 13 to 16,
I literally have nothing
to talk to them about.
My wife, if she brought home,
I'd be like,
"Hey, man.
You go to my golf club, right?
[ Laughter ]
Have fun with my wife.
Just don't stay out too late."
16, driving?
-Yes.
-I mean, L.A. kid.
Got to learn how to drive,
right?
-It comes out of nowhere.
You're gonna see.
All of the sudden,
your nice, little kids are like,
their friends are are
all driving.
My daughter is getting her
license next month.
She drives around with
the Driver's Ed guy,
which is cool, but then
she's got to practice with us,
me and my wife.
And you're in the...
The Driver's Ed guy
has the brake.
So he's, like, safe.
I'm with my 16-year-old
daughter, and I don't --
I'm nervous for her.
'Cause, like, there's
a partition and you can't...
I don't know how
I'm gonna hit the brake.
Like, dive over and push on it.
So I'm just like...
I don't want her to get hurt.
Me, I don't think
I'm going to die.
Which I'm almost to like,
"You know what?
I've had enough."
[ Laughter ]
I don't mind me dying,
but this kid's got a nice --
So I want to help her.
So when she went to
school one day,
I went out in our family car
and sneakily installed a brake.
I had one of the guys that
knows what he is doing
put a brake on my side,
so just in case, when
we're driving around...
-You have a driver's
side brake on your car now?
-Just, like, a pull thing.
Nobody knows about it.
My kid don't know about it.
I never had to use it with her.
My wife, though,
we were driving,
we got into the car,
and she was like,
"Before we go to dinner,
I'd love to go to
this antique store,"
and I was just like --
chhhhkkkkk.
[ Laughter ]
I don't know.
I feel -- that's a little,
whatever.
A little wacky.
-You got -- we've talked
about the first bat mitzvah.
You've got another one coming
up? Or have you had it?
-We had the bat mitzvah
a couple weeks ago.
It was the Sweet 16.
-Got them both out of
the way now?
-Cost a lot of money,
those things.
-While you were watching theirs,
did it remind you of
your bar mitzvah?
-[ Laughing ]
My kid's bat mitzvah was like,
an extravaganza.
I don't even know
what's the hell's happening.
All insane dancing and
everyone's --
there's sexuality
running around.
But my bar mitzvah was
just in the basement
at my parent's house.
I think we went to
the temple in the day.
My parents maybe bought some
meatballs or something,
put it downstairs
in the basement.
Some neighbors came over,
I think.
But that was the first time
I jammed.
My guitar teacher had a band,
and he was the band.
He let me play "My Sharona."
I played "My Sharona"
when I was 13,
and all my friends
gathered around
and I played "My Sharona"
and I was singing.
All my New Hampshire friends
were like,
"Sandler can sing, man."
I was looking people directly
in the eyes, just going --
[ Imitates guitar ]
That was, like,
my first time --
-That's very formative.
I feel like that's what you
would want to hear
about a bar mitzvah.
Like, you crossed a threshold
there.
-I swear to God, I think I went
to bed that night going,
"I gotta...I'm gonna be
a rock star one day.
And then, I swear to God,
I went to NYU
and I thought I was gonna be
a rock star until I got to NYU,
and in my hallway, there were,
like, five other guys
playing guitar,
just doing everything.
[ Imitates guitar ] Everything.
I was just going,
"I gotta be a comedian.
There's no way I'm gonna
compete with that."
-I want to talk about
the new film, which is great.
We'll be right back with
more from Adam Sandler.